Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism living.
Thank you for supporting the
sponsors of this show. 99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for
all things graphic design related.
Go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim
to see the projects that I've put up,
including the mockups and drafts of
the book cover for the four hour body
Ex-officio Ex-officio and I go way back
ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you
can see the clothing that I've used for
traveling through 20 plus countries,
including the underwear.
By the way,
that's about half of my
underwear drawer right now,
ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you
can also see the viral video that I put
out, which shows you how to travel
the world with 10 pounds or less.
As always,
you can subscribe to this podcast on
iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well
as every other episode by going to four
hour work week.com forward slash podcast
spell it all out or you can go to four
hour workweek.com and just click on
podcast feedback. If you have feedback,
I would love your thoughts, anything at
all who you'd like to see on this show,
ping me on Twitter at t Ferris. That's
twitter.com forward slash t f e R R,
I s s or on facebook@facebook.com forward
slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two
s's.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
For those of you new to the program,
this is where I try to
deconstruct excellence.
I talked to people who are the
best in the world, what they do,
and try to distill or extract the tools
and tips and resources that you can use,
and this episode is a very unusual
one, a very fun one, a very useful one.
I hope the episode guest is Mark Goodman.
Mark Goodman has been a resident futurist
with the FBI and worked as a senior
advisor to Interpol.
Specifically.
He's considered one of the world's
leading authorities on global security.
And in this episode we'll go very deep
into the digital underground to expose
the many ways that criminals,
corporations, countries,
organized crime and the list goes on are
using emerging technologies against you
and some of the simple steps that you
can take to decrease your vulnerability.
Sure.
Three d printers can produce
AK 47 [inaudible] bioterrorist
can now download the
recipe for Spanish flu and cartels are
using fleets of drones to carry drugs
across borders. All of which we'll touch
on. But what else is waiting for you?
What else is potentially targeting
you right now? We'll dig into it all.
And this is not from a paranoid nutjob
and I think it's important to underscore
this.
This is from a very pragmatic,
real life oriented problem
solver who has been
hired by people like the FBI and Interpol.
This is an informed insider and he
will describe the wild west that is the
internet.
And in that wild west ignorance is
no excuse for being defenseless.
If you want to hear about current and
future threats and simple defensive steps
you can take, then this interview
is for you. So without further ado,
please meet Mark Goodman.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen, boys
and girls. This is Tim Ferriss.
And welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show.
I am so excited I can barely enunciate
properly because I have Mark Goodman on
the show and I'll give a quick bio for
mark and you'll very quickly realized why
I'm excited to have him on a, and this
is pretty much directly from the bio,
but he is, he's spent a career in law
enforcement in many different capacities.
Uh, that includes work as a futurist for
the FBI who knew they had such a thing,
a senior adviser to Interpol and also
on the street as a police officer. Uh,
he's the founder of the Future Crimes
Institute and the chair for Policy Law and
ethics at Singularity University
where I've had some involvement, uh,
often at Nasa Ames and he's continued
to investigate the often terrifying
intersection of science or technology.
And crime and uncovering all sorts of
different nascent threats and combating
the darker sides of technology,
which I think don't get as much sort
of radio time perhaps as all of the
promise, uh, that, that we, that we hear
about and the benefits of Moore's law.
Uh, he is also the author of
the forthcoming future crimes.
And subtitle pretty much tells you
a lot of what you need to know.
Everything is connected, everyone is
vulnerable and what we can do about it.
So mark, thank you so much for
being on the show. Thank you Tammy.
It's an honor to be here with you and
I am thrilled to have you on because I
wanted to grab you as quickly as I could
because I think that you are going to
be getting interviewed a lot, uh,
in the, in the upcoming months. Uh,
because many people are
completely unaware of.
I think the,
the threats that are not only in some
cases ubiquitous now or at least,
uh, upcoming, but, uh, soon we'll
be right at our doorsteps. And,
uh,
just as some background for people who
are listening because I've had a lot of
public exposure since the unexpected
success of the first book. I've really,
he,
uh,
come to realize this in a very personal
way and I've had people try to hack my
sites, hack my phone, uh,
impersonate different people in my life
to get information from other people.
It's been a real fast education
and cloak and dagger stuff.
But I wanted to make sure I,
I gave a very brief overview,
but is there anything from your background
or bio that I missed that I should
share with folks?
Uh, one thing you didn't mention is the
fact that I'm a huge fan of Tim Ferris.
I really love the four hour work week
and it's quite an honor for me to be
speaking with you today.
I actually got one of the earliest
additions of the book and some of the
entrepreneurship, uh, suggestions
that you cover. It, uh,
were ideas that I tried to implement
in law enforcement and a with some
difficulty, but I tried and it was
a pretty good fun and actually, uh,
took your advice on some of the things you
did. I went on an information diet, uh,
not a real diet but an information
diet. And I also, uh, you know,
have a love of foreign language the
way you do and actually enrolled in the
heart and actually in Berlin, in
Germany. Uh, just the way you did.
So thank you for your book.
That's something else I wanted
to mention right off the top.
Oh well that of course completely
makes my week and a bit of shooting.
I hope so. Dunkin shoot, I
hope you had fun. That was a,
I had a great time at the heart
nuptual in Berlin. Um, and you know,
I think that that language is a,
is a,
is a metaphor for so many
different aspects of life and the,
the becoming fluent in a language or
becoming fluent in technology I think can
sound very intimidating to people,
but it doesn't have to be super,
super complicated. But,
but, but before we dig in,
I'm going to try something a
little different and that is to do,
we're going to do the interview in German.
We're going to do the interview in German
and I'll try to teach you Swahili. No,
I thought that we might do just a little
bit of calisthenics by doing some rapid
fire questions first just to
loosen up the joints. Great.
And then we can jump into
a, all of the, the, uh,
the spy versus spy stuff,
which I am absolutely obsessed with,
which a lot of people might not realize.
But before we do that,
I have to get into the, the really
important stuff. Such as, uh,
Sean Connery came to your house for
dinner. What would you cook them?
What I cook him. I don't know if he'd
eat, but I'd make him some drinks.
I'm sure you'd have a nice drink.
What would you, what's,
what's the cocktail or the
choice? I think for him, a Martini.
He'd be a Martini kind of guy.
Janie Kinda guy. Uh, do you have
any favorite documentaries or,
uh,
or films that come to mind?
God, I love film. Uh, and I
love a stupid eighties comedy.
So Ghostbusters, uh, it
was great. And you know,
anything of that genre or anything
with Bill Murray or Dan Akroyd in it.
I'm a fan and of course I like all those
ads hacking movies like war games and
sneakers and that type of stuff.
So of the, of the, uh,
at the hacking genre or the
crime slash spice genre,
what movie,
what movies that you like our closest
to reality and furthest from reality?
Uh, that's interesting. Uh,
it's very funny when you see how a
Hollywood goes out and portrays hacking on
the screen. Uh, you know,
most hackers get a good laugh of what
they taught type at the c prompt.
It's pretty funny. But, uh,
I think actually I have to give a hat tip
to a Walter Parks who did the original
war games because considering that it
was in the early eighties before most
people were thinking about computers,
I mean modems where, you know,
super slow and incredibly rare.
And the fact that he was able to bring
that hacker type out there and show that
the Department of defense was connected
to the Internet and you could change
your grades.
I mean he did that 30 or so years ago.
So that was really awesome
and I think that's great.
Some of the other hacker movies, a
Sandra Bullock, the net, you know,
it was a nice movie,
not particularly realistic,
but there were elements of truth in it.
So they're just been a lot of
silly hacker movies out there. Um,
because as I've been told, it's
difficult to show, you know,
cool hacker stuff on the screen in
a way that people don't understand.
Yeah. I had a computer scientist friend
of mine also said that you can always,
it's always amusing to watch a hacker's
typing and movies because they never
used the space bar.
And a,
you can tell when people are bs thing
on a keyboard because they never,
you never hear the
distinctive sort of thing.
Lack of the thumb hitting the space bar
as you will know,
all the best hackers never use the space.
That's right. Very Tom. All the, all the
divorce act type was out there and like,
like Matt Mullenweg. Uh, let's see. The,
what is the book that you're most likely
to give as a gift or the book that
you've given most as a gift to people?
Uh, this sounds like bs, but it's actually
been your book. Uh, I have to say,
I'll give it to a ton of people. I
have, I run into people all the time,
both in law enforcement,
friends of mine, uh,
folks that are struggling with their
careers and trying to think about
opportunities to see the world in a
different way. And I know bullshit.
I've actually given away
about 10 copies of your book.
Wow. Well, I appreciate that
and I'm my publisher. Thanks
you for that as well. Yes,
that was before I had my own book
in the future. Of course my book.
But up until then, you, you
were my favorite. Well, I'll
take, I'll take a runner up.
When your book comes
out, are there any, uh,
are there any fiction books
that you particularly like?
It doesn't have to be science fiction
or any particular genre, but any,
any fiction books that have been
very influential in your life?
You know, there were some great, I love
the Old Street Chi Street crime drama. So,
you know,
having grown up in New York City and
kind of been very in tuned with the New
York City Police Department,
uh,
there was a book called one police plaza
by a guy called William [inaudible],
which I thought was awesome
and just really got a,
what policing was and what
policing was all about.
And I thought that was pretty amazing.
Very cool.
Now I'd love to check that out.
I know less about the police than I
do the, uh, the other aspects of the,
of the military, oddly enough.
You know, so it's, it's the,
the law enforcement that I
have the most contact with,
I have the least knowledge of,
uh,
I understand this ironic.
Uh, let's see here.
I'm not going to ask too many
more of these because I want to,
I want to jump into, um,
of course the, uh, the,
you're the subject that
are your expertise,
but do you have any
particular morning routines?
What does the first hour
of your day look like?
Ah,
I wake up,
I take my dog out for a walk
and then I have a breakfast,
which I really enjoy,
catch up on some news emails and
then go on and take on the day.
What time do you typically wake up?
It depends.
I do a lot of traveling,
so it depends on what time zone
I'm in and how jet lagged I meant,
but I'm more on the early side these days,
I'd say.
Got It. Uh, and that is, that's like a
7:00 AM kind of thing or a success. Right.
Uh, yesterday I was up at five the day
before I was up at five and then, uh,
mostly I would say six 37
something in that timeframe.
Got It. And uh, do you change your,
how does your routine change on the
weekends? How do you decompress if you,
if you do?
Uh, I like to go for hikes.
I like to go outside,
like going to the movie theater is
seeing films, hanging out with friends,
all the kind of standard
stuff. But, uh, you know,
for the past year when
I was writing the book,
it mostly was my butt in chair typing.
Right. Uh, when you think
of the word successful,
who's the first person who
comes to mind? Hmm. Wow.
There's so many different ways
to define success. Uh, I mean,
Martin Luther King Join,
you know,
is one of the first guys
that pops into my head.
Clinton was a produce
successful politician. There
are lots of folks out there.
Uh, and of course, you know,
any of the entrepreneurs
like Steve jobs and the like.
Got It. Uh, so let's jump into,
uh, the, the subject matter
at hand and, uh, and,
and we can tackle this from
many different perspectives,
but perhaps you could give, uh, maybe,
maybe if you facts or examples of things
that might surprise people in the world
of whether it's currently existing crime
or things that you see right on the
horizon coming down the pike.
Sure. I'd be happy to do that. Basically,
my take on this is that folks are very
focused on the cyber crime of today.
Every day in the news,
whether it be the New York Times
or the Wall Street Journal,
we're hearing that target was hacked and
Home Depot is hacked and JP Morgan was
hacked.
And what's interesting to me is that the
media treats all of these as distinct
incidents. Like, Oh, another
company was hacked, you know,
a bunch of celebrities had their
naked photos. Uh, you know, uh, uh,
tipped off by a hacker.
That stuff is all treated as
if it were an individual act.
And what people don't see,
uh,
from a 35,000 foot view is that
there's a systemic issue going on,
which is something I try to mention in
future crimes. It's the fact that we have,
uh, thanks to Moore's law,
which you mentioned earlier,
we're just moving at an exponential rate.
And so we're plugging more and more
things into the Internet. And the fact is,
as you well know,
software is eating the world.
So everything is becoming software.
Everything is becoming a computer.
A car is not a car anymore.
It's no longer a mechanical device that
is 250 computer chips in it at a minimum.
So a car is basically a
Unix box that we ride in.
An elevator is a computer that
takes us from floor to floor. Um,
and as Cory Doctorow says,
an airplane is a flying solares box
with a bunch of industrial controllers.
So people don't realize that.
And the big takeaway from that is that
never has there been a computer system
that could not be hacked. In other
words, every computer system is hackable.
There are no unhackable machines.
And that has some really
profound consequences for us
as a society and the world
that we're building because we're about
to add between 50 and 200 billion new
devices to the Internet, uh,
uh, to the Internet of things.
Depending on who you ask. CISCOE,
we'll say 50 billion by the year,
2020 until says 200
billion by the year 2020.
The impact of that is that we're
going to go from an Internet that is
theoretically or metaphorically the size
of a golf ball today to one that is the
size of the sun, right? Massive,
massive improvements. Reasons.
Yeah. We're just at the very,
very earliest days of the Internet.
And so the,
I guess you'd say mistake that a lot
of people make is they think we're
technologically advanced today.
Uh,
but they have no idea of the tsunami
of technology that's coming our way
tomorrow.
And I think also to underscore that,
that that human beings intrinsically
are very bad at thinking in exponential
terms. Uh, they're just, they're, they're
very bad at predicting. For instance,
I mean the, the, the answers
to a lot of these old riddles,
such as you take one grain of rice and
you double it for each square on the
chessboard and how many,
how many pieces of rice do you have,
how many grains of rice do
you have by the end? And it's,
it's very hard for people to anticipate,
uh,
how quickly things can
change. Uh, for instance, uh,
I've listened to a number of your talks,
you have a great ted
talk and the fact that,
and this may even be more accelerated now,
I think your talk was in 2012,
but the DNA sequencing is proceeding
at five times Moore's law, uh,
in the impact that that has
on a sort of privacy and,
uh, the, the, uh, the weaponization of,
of different types of code.
Right. And, um, there's,
there's another term that you
also used a phrase rather than,
that's the technological arms race,
sort of the,
the white hat versus the black hat.
And then you have a bunch of folks
in between. So I'd be curious to hear
sort of where things
stand now compared to a,
it a horrible 60 hour siege in Mumbai
that you've talked about before. Were,
were terrorists,
you know,
built their own ops center in Pakistan
to monitor the progress of these attacks
in real time and where they'd be executing
people with a hand gun, one hand wall,
looking at their cell phone in another,
which gave them a huge situational on
tactical advantage over the police. Uh,
but those were with
relatively primitive devices,
all things considered because
I think that was in 2006 or,
or somewhere along those lines.
Right?
The 2008 in Mumbai. Yeah.
I apologize. And, uh,
and that I remember doing research
for the, for the four hour body.
At one point I was chatting with a
scientist who shall remain unnamed,
but he was talking about how negligent
it was in his mind for a very well known
tech Titan to have released all of his,
uh,
genetic data or as is his DNA
sequencing, uh, because people could,
uh,
create personalized biological
weapons to attack him.
And it's,
it's sort of,
I think to the uninitiated seems like
complete science fiction, like a fantasy,
but, uh, where are we with that
type of thing? I mean, does that,
is that already being
used on people? Uh, yeah.
So you're spot on actually
a, with everything that
you just said. Uh, in fact,
the cost of sequencing human genomes has
dropped precipitously and is dropping
at five times faster than Moore's law.
So with Moore's law,
silicon based technology ones and Zeros,
that is doubling every 18 to 24
months depending on who you ask.
And Ray Kurzweil has shown
in the singularity is near,
and many times since that there is
this persistent exponential pace of
technology.
Synthetic biology and genetics are
outpacing that by a factor of five.
So a bio biological advancements
and computational biology,
we're pretty much proceeding at Moore's
law is pace until 2008 when there were
some massive breakthroughs
in genetic sequencing,
which made it go five times faster.
So what is the result of that? Well,
there'll be tremendous opportunities
for each one of us to know our genome.
For example,
today,
most people would certainly never consider
going in for a full genetic, you know,
genome sequencing prohibitively expensive.
When the US government launched
the human genome project, uh,
back a decade or so ago,
it,
they allocated $3 billion to
sequence the first person's genome.
Uh, and they didn't get it done. They
didn't complete it. Craig Ventnor,
a a world famous biologist came
in and worked on the project,
built upon the work done by
the human genome project,
and he was able to sequence in full the
first human being for a cost of $300
million about 10 years ago.
And fast forward to today,
you can actually get a full
genetic sequencing for $1,000.
And there are companies like 23 and
me that will offer you partial genetic
sequencing for just $99. Uh,
without a doubt, within a few years,
it'll be the price of a cup of coffee.
Everybody will have their
full genetic sequence.
So that's great news for medicine,
right? Uh, every cancer can be treated.
You will know your proclivities
for certain diseases.
We'll be able to, you know,
have really massive impacts on health
care. But there's a flip side of that.
When it cost $3 billion to sequence the
human genome and pieces of equipment to
do that,
we're in the tens of millions of dollars.
Only the government or the wealthiest
universities could afford that. Now,
equipment that's sold on Ebay a year ago
for $100,000 can be bought for 10,000
or a thousand today.
That is putting the tools of genetics
and synthetic biology in the hands of the
common man.
So they're actually high school clubs
that are doing a genetic sequencing today,
right? They have lots of groups.
There's something called [inaudible],
which is a high school in college
competition that focuses on this. So it's,
today's kids are very much at the
cutting edge of science. And again,
they'll do all different types of
cool stuff. At singularity university,
we had a startup that was grating up glow
in the dark plant because they thought
it would be cool,
let's do that and you can do that.
But the challenge with these things are,
is that nuts?
Not everybody playing with these tools,
whether it be genetics, synthetic biology,
robotics,
artificial intelligence is of a kind
heart and there are criminals and
terrorists and bad guys that now for the
first time have access to these tools
and I know you're chomping at the bit
so I'll shut up for a second and then
happy to give some examples of
what bad guys are doing with bio.
Okay.
We're going to come right back to,
I want to ask a very personal
question which is so 23 in me.
I've always been nervous about having
my own name associated with genetic data
and so,
uh,
I have thought to myself and
talked with other people about,
well perhaps you should have a friend
pay for your 23 and me who is of a
different gender so that if
that data is ever compromised,
it's tossed out a or misattributed
or using a pseudonym,
let's say with an authorized account
under a separate credit card,
et Cetera, shipped to an address that
isn't associated with your name. So that,
that, that data cannot be used
against you in some fashion. Is that,
is that para, is that paranoia
or is that preparedness? Is that,
is that a practical thing in your mind
or something else? I'm just curious
fits paranoia.
You and I are both paranoid because that's
the exact advice I give to my friends
that want to do the test.
So I don't know whether or not this
violates their terms and services.
But the simple fact of the matter is we
have no idea how they're going to use
that genetic information.
And there are lots of sites out there
on some I mentioned in the book,
one is called patients like me,
patients like me was a medical site
where people were meant to be sharing
confidential medical information
with each other and you know,
get help for particularly rarer diseases.
And they had something called the mood
form where people were talking about
psychotic breaks,
suicidality and the like.
And it turns out the folks
that were running it,
we're actually releasing all of that
information. Insurance companies,
and it was mentioned very clearly in
their terms of service that they do. So.
So you think you may be doing something
that's safe and secure and private,
but in fact, often you're not. So I would
always look at the terms of services.
Again, I don't know what the terms of
services are for 23 and me specifically,
but I would say the following,
if I wanted to get genetic testing,
I definitely share your concern and
would not be doing it under my own name
because we simply don't know
where this technology is going.
We have a Nivea Tay about, you know,
the future and what it might look like.
I'm not sure if you ever
saw the movie Gattica.
Uh, I, I've seen the previews
so that as far as I've gone,
the short story is,
it's kind of a dystopian future where
everybody is judged based upon their DNA.
So let's say you want to be a scientist
or you want to be an astronaut based
upon your genetic profile, they'll
say, nope, you know what, Tim,
you're not quite what we're looking for.
And everybody's social strata is
determined by their DNA and what that,
what people presume that means.
So I'd won't say that exactly.
We'll be living in the Gatica future.
But for example,
if there are genetic markers for, um,
uh, sexual orientation for example,
which some people suggest there are,
there are definitely a genetic markers
for predispositions to violence,
could be for schizophrenia
and other diseases.
So the opportunities from a
public policy, law and ethics, um,
perspective to have your genetic material,
a leak or the information about you and
get out into the public sphere and I'm
sure will happen. You know,
we know today, uh, that, uh,
presidential candidates are forced one
way or the other to release their medical
records to show that they're
fit and ready for office. Uh,
I guarantee that that will be happening
with presidential genomes in the future.
Uh, and in fact, I talked about this, I
wrote an article with two friends of mine,
Steven Kotler, who you may know, and
Andrew Hessel as synthetic biologists.
And it was in the Atlantic monthly and
it was called hacking the president's DNA
and was all about what those risks
would look like. And the, uh, the, uh,
number of bio threats that
could be launched if you
had access to somebody whose
genetic material.
So for most folks,
I don't think they have to
worry about biohacking today,
but from a privacy perspective, I think
I would definitely take precautions.
And the ones that you mentioned about
using a prepaid credit card for example,
or having it shipped to a third party
and all of that stuff I think are good
logical,
common sense steps to take.
So what are some other uh, yeah,
and just for what it's worth,
I want to do like a,
an urban myth check here because of
course I get all excited about this stuff.
And when I was doing a research for the
four hour chef and became fascinated by
marksmanship and hunting,
of course that very quickly leads to
the prepper communities and there's the
good, bad and the ugly there. Uh, and
there were some very extreme edge cases,
but,
uh,
I was speaking with a very well
credentialed and the example he gave was a
personalized weapon.
Doesn't have to be a
synthetically engineered,
super fancy Psi Phi like dart
or pill or anything like that.
It could be that you know,
someone's predisposed to a disease and
that you can accelerate the onset of,
say, a neurodegenerative disease by
blowing molybdenum into their face at a,
at a, at a public event where
they wouldn't even, they,
they might not even register
that that's what happened.
But if you want it to say,
take a longterm,
short position on their stock and they're
running a publicly traded company that
it doesn't have to be that type of crime,
doesn't need to be the implement the
diagnostics and the determining of the
target could be sophisticated,
but the actual attack does not have to be,
uh,
something futuristic.
I agree with that.
I'll give you a perfect example.
There's a medicine called Warfarin,
which is a blood thinner
and there's a certain,
a small percentage of people that have a
genetic marker that makes them allergic
to that and it's deadly if taken.
So that would be a perfect example.
It's a common pharmaceutical.
They exist today.
And it's not something that you
can see by looking at somebody,
whether or not they're
allergic to Warfarin,
but if ingested right now you have that
additional piece of information and you
know about it and it could be fatal.
Yeah. Yeah. That's crazy. I mean, yeah,
and I think so don't do that. Kids. Yeah.
Don't commit bio homicide
and, uh, you know, it's also
a, it brings up, uh, and I,
and I want you to give some examples,
but a misconception I think that a
lot of people have about criminals or
particularly a terrorist specifically,
and that is that they're,
they're just uneducated.
Uh,
and maybe you can shed some light here,
but it seems that there actually
seems to be a disproportionately high
percentage of very,
very,
very well educated people
who then are recruited, uh,
by, uh, Milton groups as,
you know, operatives or,
or terrorists. It, it's, it's, uh,
I think people underestimate the,
perhaps the, the, the
intellectual horsepower of, of,
of some people who could perpetrate
these types of crimes. Um,
but I would love to hear,
certainly examples. Um,
you mentioned you might have a
couple of different examples. Sure.
Which I'd love to hear.
Yeah. I mean, on the terrorist
front, you're exactly right.
People tend to underestimate them.
You know,
when we were first going into Iraq and
Afghanistan where talked about people
with towels on their
heads living in caves,
and what could they possibly do
to defeat us? And as we saw it,
they were able to put up quite a
hell of a fight. Uh, and you know,
[inaudible] Hawaii,
I'll just where hearing who was a Osama
bin Ladin as number two was an MD.
He was a trained physician,
right?
So there are any number of doctors that
are in these terrorist organizations.
We've seen them recruiting
specifically on tourists, chalkboards.
They're looking for people
with scientific backgrounds,
with technological backgrounds. One
terrorist up by the name of your hobby,
double o seven, he took the double
o seven from James Bond, uh,
and he was like basically the CIO for
al Qaeda for a while running their
technology. Uh, in the wake
of the Snowden disclosures,
there's been a ton of chatter
on terrorists chat boards, uh,
talking about the importance of
encryption. So they follow the news very,
very closely and are
paying attention to it.
They show tremendous sophistication.
And let's go back to bio, for example,
the terrorist organization,
I'm Sham Reiki of the folks that
carried out the 1995 exactly.
Severin get hustle on the Tokyo
subway that occurred at 95.
What most people didn't realize about
[inaudible] Rinko is the fact that they
had a bio weapons project.
They spent $1 million a year for,
for 10 years from 1985 to 1995 trying
to develop a powerful bio weapon.
And the science wasn't there yet
for them to be able to do it.
That's why they went with the
chemical sarin gas attack today.
Things like that would be much more
trivial given the wide availability of
biotoxins and other type of infectious
threats that are available online.
The code is there,
you can download it,
basically build some of these things in
your basement or garage and release them.
In other area where we see terrorists,
uh,
playing in really interesting ways are
both robotics and social media and open
source intelligence.
And I'll just give a few crazy examples.
So during the terror attack
at the Westgate Mall that
occurred in Nairobi about
a year ago, we saw a, the
tourists from all Shabaab.
The militants were incredibly
sophisticated in how they
were using social media
and Twitter.
They were live tweeting the entire
event and they were actually mocking the
Kenyan police force and military
guards throughout the incident,
putting out information,
uh,
adding to the confusion and Isis or the
Islamic state has been doing the same
exact thing you mentioned earlier.
Also the 2008 Mumbai terrorist attack.
In my humble opinion,
that was perhaps one of the
most sophisticated terrorist
attacks we've seen to
date. From a technological
perspective, uh,
10 terrorists were able to keep a city,
a metropolitan area of 20 million people
completely shut down for 60 hours.
So 10 guys not just armed with
standard weapons. Ak 47 it's RDX,
explosives, hand grenades. But
these guys had night vision goggles.
They had satellite phones, satellite
imagery, encrypted blackberries.
They use Skype type of voice
communications during the
incident because they had
all that technology.
They had phenomenal situational awareness,
situational awareness that beat the
capacity of the Indian national guard and
the Mumbai Police to respond.
And they used it to great effect
to actually kill more people.
There's an example I talk about in the
book of a man called [inaudible] who was
staying at the Taj Mahal Hotel in
Mumbai. Um, you may have been there.
It's one of the most
beautiful hotels in the world.
And when the terrorist
took over the hotel,
they started going room to room
trying to find more hostages.
And they came across Mr Romo party who
was on the top floor in a suite at the
Taj and they broke into his
room and they said to him, well,
who are you and what are you doing
here? And he said, oh no, I'm nobody.
Leave me alone. I'm just an
innocent school teacher. Well,
the terrorists were dumb. But to
your point about not being that dumb,
they looked at this guy and staying in a
suite at the Taj Mahal, beautiful hotel,
and they said, there's no way any Indian
school teacher could afford this suite.
They picked up his id at his bedside and
then they phoned it in via a satellite
phone to the terrorist war room that was
set up across the border in Pakistan.
There in the war room, the terrorists
were monitoring, uh, live, uh, a,
they had ibn, uh, CNN, BBC,
I'll just Syrah and a bank of computers
where they were doing real time research.
So you had the 10, uh, uh,
operatives from luxury aid,
Toiba al Qaeda affiliate based in Pakistan
that we're carrying out the attack,
uh, broken down into five
teams of two terrorists.
And then you had the tourist war room.
So when they phoned in the name of
this guy to the tourist war room,
they simply googled him. They came
across his photograph. As it turns out,
he was not a school teacher.
He was the head of the,
one of the second largest
banks in India called ing.
And they came across this photo.
And then we know from the
intercepted conversation,
which we only discovered after the fact
that the terrorist war room said, hey,
we found a picture of your guy
is your hostage heavyset? Yes.
Does he have glasses? Yes. Is he kind
of bald? Yes. Okay. We found him.
The terrorist then said to their
ops center, what shall we do?
And then the order came down,
kill him.
So the fact of the matter is,
back in 2008,
terrorists were using search engines like
Google to determine who shall live and
who shall die. And No, it's a black swan
event. And I know you talk about those.
The fact of the matter is, when you're
sharing and Facebook, it's not just,
you know, the media and
marketing companies that you
need to be concerned about.
When you share openly,
everybody has access to this.
And even though it's a black swan,
we're event that could be terrorist
organized criminals as well.
And I should, I think you, you, uh,
I think it's a terrifying example,
particularly when you consider that
2008 was the stone ages compared to the,
the, um, the, the
implications of big data and,
and a ubiquitous availability of tools
today and the sophistication certainly
have a lot of those tools,
uh,
including reverse image search and things
like that through Google or tonight or
others. The, the Black Swan events. Also,
just because a black swan
event is considered a black
swan event to the victims
doesn't mean black swan event. Uh, I,
he a a low probability random event.
It could be completely engineered as it
was in this particular case through a
extensive preparations on the part
of the, of the terrorists. So the,
the, uh, I'd love to
talk a little bit about,
uh, a, a phrase I've heard you mentioned
before and that is public safety is too
important to leave to the professionals.
So there,
there are a number of ways I'd
like to try to unpack that.
The first is just as a, um, uh,
to try to bring out my
inner prepper. So in, in if,
if you live in San Francisco,
in a city like New York City
or San Francisco or Chicago,
what are the things that should be
keeping you up at night that you should be
thinking about mitigating as
risks are Black Swan events?
Well, traffic, but it's
not a black swan events
keeps me up at night. Uh,
when I talked about that,
I was speaking more broadly
about kind of the cyber threat,
but it's also true in physical
space as well. I mean,
the fact of the matter is that the line
between kind of order in society and
chaos is actually quite
thin in law enforcement.
They talk about the thin blue line and
I was a patrol officer in Los Angeles
during the La Riots.
And what I realized is that the police
are in charge as long as the public wants
them to be in charge. Once the public
decides that they are not in charge,
you are no longer in charge.
I think La had 1.7 police officers for
every hundred thousand citizens at that
point. And so if you make the
citizens really, really mad, uh,
as was the case during
the Rodney King incident,
then it's over and there's nothing
you can do. So, uh, in physical space,
I mean all the basic stuff that you
talked about, the prepper movement,
but the Red Cross would give you the
same type of advice or the California
office of emergency services,
Fema.
There are any number of good checklists
out there about having water and food
and, you know, just be prepared
to have an emergency plan.
All of that is really good and useful.
And I also had unfortunately,
uh,
the opportunity to be in New York City
down at seven world trade on nine 11.
So that was another experience
that I happen to have lived
through. And you know,
it that brought out the best of people
in that particular instance where you saw
a total and complete strangers being as
warm and helpful to one another as they
could. Um, so it can
really go both ways. Uh,
when I talk about public safety
being too important to leave to the
professionals, what I
would say is that, uh,
people often abdicate their concept
of safety to the police or to the
authorities and think that
everything will be just fine.
And mostly in our physical space,
in the developed world where we have rule
of law. So, you know, think Australia,
Western Europe, uh, you
know, in North America,
that's a system that works quite well.
If you look at what's going on, you know,
with Al Shabaab and others in
Africa, it's a different story. But,
uh, in cyberspace it's a
complete, uh, you know,
every man for himself type scenario.
What I find fascinating is,
is that from the most part,
law enforcement has abdicated any
responsibility for cybercrime. Now,
I know that some of my colleagues
in law enforcement might, you know,
take issue with that and
certainly they're trying hard,
but the volume of the threat and the
nature of the technology makes law
enforcement, uh, nearly impossible as a
solution for the cyber threat. You know,
I talk about law enforcement is a
nation state type solution, right?
A policemen in New York and not make
an arrest in Moscow and vice a versa.
And so law enforcement is a local
solution to a global problem.
So no matter how good the cops get,
even though there are organizations like
Interpol also that are trying to make a
difference,
they're just fundamentally mismatch.
And that's what we need to deal with. You
know, if somebody came into your house,
uh, and broke into it and stole
something, you'd dial nine one one.
There's some kids spray painted your car
or your house, you'd call the police,
you'd file a report for vandalism.
And yet we have the equivalent of these
things going on every single day in our
homes and our computers on our
cell phones, on our tablets.
And if you dialed nine one one
to report a computer virus,
the cops would come for you as opposed to
sending a car to investigate it. So, uh,
I think from that angle,
we need to get average and
everyday citizens involved
in this. On the one hand,
law enforcement has very
limited resources. It
doesn't work internationally.
And not all agencies are particularly
well schooled. On the cyber threat.
Whereas in, you know, this living
in San Francisco and Silicon Valley,
there's tremendous talent in the
private sector that fully is versed in
technology.
There's a global community of people that
could contribute significantly to this
problem. And I think that it'd be a
great opportunity to get them engaged.
And the last thing I would mention in
particularly since we are living so much
of our lives online,
you know,
staring at screens on our smart phones
or on our computers every single day,
there's a part of our life that
is taking place in cyberspace.
And yet we don't have a Common Defense
Force for cyberspace. So, you know, a,
for a hundred years
we've had reserve army,
we've had reserved and
auxiliary police officers.
We don't have any equivalent
for that, uh, in cyberspace.
And so when the big cyber attack comes,
we're going to have a paucity of
resources and talent to respond.
So one of the things I call for is the
building of a national cyber reserve
corps. Take average ordinary citizens,
men and women, young and old.
It doesn't matter.
Put them through a background,
get them cleared and part of the solution
because we definitely need their help.
So I definitely want to
come back to that type of,
uh, distributed or
crowdsourced workforce. Uh,
and on a, on a related note, I
want to talk a little bit about,
uh, the physical world.
So meet space and those
crowdsourcing.
We'll give you some great examples
when we come back about criminals.
Crowdsourcing.
Okay, great. And, and we can talk
about the counter forces to then also,
so I remember going through a northern
emergency response team training course,
uh,
which was,
which was organized by the San
Francisco police and fire departments.
So this was not a fringe group
teaching this class. Right.
And I remember him paraphrasing here,
but roughly they said they,
they pulled the audience said, okay,
how many people live in San Francisco?
How many fire engines do you think there
are? And it's something like, you know,
38 fire engines for us at,
at a minimum,
several hundred thousand people.
And the point they made was if there is a,
if there is an issue in the
event of a real event, a,
let's just call it a seven point
or higher Richter scale earthquake,
you could go and very realistically could
expect to go seven to 10 days without
food or water. Uh, and uh,
the, you know, the, the,
the fact that um, the, the Lord
of the flies type scenario,
while unlikely is not as
unlikely as people might think.
And I recall when I was writing a section
of the four hour chef called the wild
section was all about sort of
forging and hunting and uh,
preparing food without
the use of the kitchen.
I got went down the,
the prepper rat hole pretty quickly.
And uh, I remember having, uh, some
editorial feedback from the publisher,
which was critical of how
deep I went into this stuff.
And just at that moment when I
was being told that I was, uh,
it was too alarmist and too extreme,
hurricane sandy hit New York City.
And,
uh,
it was just a perfect illustration of
how ill prepared most people were a for
what is going to be, uh, a,
an increasingly common
occurrence with climate change,
at least according to a
lot of scientists who,
who've looked at the modeling of say
a hundred year storms and how it might
occur every decade or even
more frequently. But let
me, let me ask you, um,
do you think having your mentioning
mentioning biochemical a weapons or
biological agents and
how people, uh, it's,
it's become increasingly easy in a way to,
uh,
to fabricate these or to, to
engineer them. Do you, uh,
do you think having iodine tablets
and a gas masks at home is,
is overkill if you live
in a metropolitan area?
I guess it would,
I would say it depends on your philosophy
in life and how you choose to live
your life. You were talking
about, uh, you know,
30 or 40 fire engines for
the city of San Francisco.
There were nights when I was working with
the LAPD on Morning Watch to eight and
for a precinct that had
400,000 people living in it,
we had three police cars on the road.
So in that precinct,
now we had other guys and other
precincts that we could call, but that's,
you know, three police cars,
six guys and Gals, you know,
for 400,000 people. So yes,
the thin blue line can
be quite thin at times.
And I'm always encouraging of people
to be prepared to have a plan,
to be cognizant of the threats.
Now you can take that to an extreme.
You can't say, I have to have a
bunker. I need to live underground.
We need to be prepared for it.
You know, nuclear Armageddon.
And that's not the way that
I choose to live my life.
But I think common sense tools, first
aid kit, having iodine, perhaps,
uh, Opportunity, uh,
to have tablets to make sure that
you have access to clean water, um,
that's decontaminate it and things like
that. I think that just is logical.
I don't think there's anything
over the top about that at all
with international travel. Um, and uh,
we're not going to get into necessarily
kidnapping and all of that, but I wanna,
I wanna I wanna use this as a [inaudible],
not have a great kidnapping example.
We'll, all right, well if you're going
to dangle that carrot in front of him,
let's go there. So I went, no, I want to
hear the kidnapping example. Let's do it.
So this is just something that occurred
in Mexico City a couple of years ago
when smart phones were first
starting to come in. Um,
the cops in Mexico noticed a
phenomena that was really weird.
So I'm sure this has happened to you.
You get off an airplane in other city
and somebody is holding a piece of
cardboard with your name on it and you
walk up to them. Have you done that? Yeah.
So guess what?
Cardboard can be hacked.
Sometimes people lie and sometimes the
person holding the sign is not the person
that you expect them to be.
So about three years ago,
four years ago in Mexico City when
smart phones first came out, uh,
organized crime groups and Narcos were
hanging out at the Mexico City Airport.
And with all the signs up,
they said,
Mr. Smith from Dow Chemicals and
Mrs. Jones from, you know, uh,
whatever the company may be,
the bad guys were sitting there and they
were using their smartphones to Google
the people whose names were on the
signs and looking for those that they
estimate it to be of the greatest net
worth. Once they figured out who that was,
the criminals were going up to the
chauffeurs and saying, you know,
here's 100 pesos. Get outta here and
we'll kill you or we'll kill you.
And they were taking the cardboard sign,
the executive flying in from New York,
San Francisco,
London would then get off the plane,
see the piece of cardboard
with her name on it,
walk up to the person who
also took the limousine,
was dressed like a limousine driver,
got into a car and was kidnapped, uh,
as a result. And they were actually a few
people that were killed. So my point is,
is that most people are very
trusting and they should be.
That's the way you want to live life.
Then you know,
you want to be happy and
think about that stuff.
But when everybody thinks like that,
those who think differently, for example,
criminals,
terrorists and others,
it's really easy to subvert the
system and cardboard can be hacked.
Yup. It's, uh, I hadn't
heard that specific example,
but that is yet another reason for me to
use pseudonyms when using car services,
uh, which, which I do. Um,
I have done for the last couple of
years just because I've had some weird
experiences with travel.
Uh, even though, uh,
you know,
this is where,
this is where the Internet really fucks
me because people think people can't run
publishing numbers.
They don't understand book economics.
So they think I have like a hundred
billion dollars and I'm like,
you got the wrong guy.
But, uh, the, the, uh,
oh God. Yeah, the, the, the
kidnappings. Terrifying. I,
I know I have known people in Argentina
and in other countries who have been
kidnapped or, or, or Columbia,
Brazil, very, very, extremely common.
I know many people who've had family
members or friends kidnapped in south and
Central America, the um, in certainly
not exclusive to this places at all.
But the,
the question I was going to ask you
is a segway to a virtual attacks and,
uh, one of the startups that, uh, I'm,
I'm close to is it used to be
called reputation defender.
It's now reputation.com.
And uh,
one of the executives there told me that
when he travels to China on business,
he will use a brand new throwaway netbook
because he does not want any of his
data compromised on his, uh,
on his hardware, you know,
if he brings a laptop with him.
Um,
if someone is traveling, uh, let's just,
let's just say it's a
business person there,
they're traveling to any
number of countries, but
let's just assume it's China.
What are the precautions
that they might take, uh,
to try to prevent any infiltration of
their data or sensitive information?
Yeah, that is an awesome,
awesome question.
And it's one that people don't think
about, uh, nearly often enough. You know,
whether it be an executive from Houston
or New York City or those in Silicon
Valley, obviously business,
we'll take them to, you know,
the most populous nation on earth,
the People's Republic of China.
And there the rules are very different
in terms of what the so called police can
do and how they will treat
you and your technology.
So all I would say is if you're
going over there for business,
play close attention.
The fact of the matter is
they're screening of you
begins when you fill out your
visa application, right?
It's nothing there is random.
So why do you have to
do a visa application?
Because they want to know who you are.
And if you're interesting,
and if you're Andy Grove from
Intel traveling into China,
they're going to pay attention to you.
And I'll give you one simple example. Uh,
and this was reported several years ago.
Andy Grove, the former chairman of Intel,
actually took a flight into Beijing.
He gave a lecture before
thousand people and uh,
presented from his laptop after his
presentation was over a two very young,
uh,
pretty Chinese women,
him and they were ever so subtly just
moving their own bodies to get him to turn
away from his own laptop. He had a lovely
conversation and when he turned around,
his laptop was gone.
Now the big mistake in that particular
case is not that he brought a laptop per
se,
but as the chairman of Intel,
he actually had the designs for
one of the latest pentium chips.
Extremely valuable intellectual
property on the computer,
the disappeared along with the laptop.
So my general rule of thumb is, you know,
laptops as you, you know,
net books, whatever they are,
they're just a couple of hundred bucks
today. If you can afford a trip to China,
you should be able to afford a laptop.
You can bring a dummy phone with you.
And just to give you an idea of
some of the information that leaks,
the minute you connect to a hotel
in a potentially hostile territory,
whether it be Iran, China, you know,
whatever country you're traveling too,
they have the ability to insert malware
onto both your phone and your computer
the minute your device connects
to their network. So you know,
when you have to log in to
the hotel webpage to pay,
that's when the handshake takes place and
that's when your device gets infected.
So that step one,
if you go ahead and leave
your laptop in any hotel safe,
routinely the hotel security
gives access to the local police.
So they all know the combinations.
Anybody can open up one of
those saves incredibly easily.
So what I would recommend
is if you bring technology,
carry it on you, uh, if
you want to hold onto it,
I wouldn't limit the amount
of information you put on it.
I would certainly consider what we call
a throwaway laptop or mobile phone and I
would make sure that those
devices were encrypted.
If you know you're going to call
10 people when you're over there,
have those 10 phone numbers and don't
walk out there with all of your contacts,
with your business plans,
with your sales figures.
The thing that mostly the Chinese
are interested in besides, uh,
intellectual property is they're very
aggressive about being helpful to their
state back industry.
So if you're over there as an American
businessman or woman or regardless of
what country you're from and you're
negotiating a deal with the Chinese,
there'll be very careful
about monitoring your email,
what you're doing and any negotiations
that you may be having with your
counterparts from your own
company in the United States,
whether it be your general counsel,
the head of sales,
they're going to take that information
and feed it to their Chinese equivalent.
Uh, in order to do that. And in fact,
there was a case that I mentioned in the
book where an executive from Coca Cola
got fished with a spear phishing email
and they were in a multibillion dollar
deal with a Chinese beverage, a state
sponsored Chinese beverage company,
and they were under bid and lost out.
So one phishing email to the right
executive crafted in the right way,
infected the computer and then the deal
was done and billions of dollars were
lost.
Wow. So the phishing email was
something like whatever it might be, uh,
your, your account is overdrawn to the
Bank of America. Click here to confirm.
And if I could just give one general tip,
something to keep in mind. And you know,
I don't know everybody that's
going to listen to your podcasts,
but I'm going to postulate that most of
your listeners actually do not know it.
Prince in Nigeria, if you get an
email from a prince in Nigeria,
do not click on it. He's not
your friend. He doesn't know you.
Yeah, very good advice.
Very, very good advice. Yeah,
the opportunity cost of missing the real
email from the prince in Nigeria pretty,
pretty low when you look
at the probabilities.
But you hit on something major
right there, which is actually,
that is one of the major causes of
infections to people's computers is that
they're clicking on the wrong link.
And in the old days you used to be able
to tell a phishing email because they
use bad language, bad
English, bad grammar.
Now they're perfectly well crafted
and a spear phishing email targeting,
targeting a specific individual
or executive is even more so.
So you have to really careful.
Basically,
my general rule of thumb is don't click
on links. If people send me a link,
I'll call them and say, Hey, did you send
this to me? And they think I'm crazy,
but I don't click on links.
Yeah. Well did Ditto for attachments,
which can be executable files.
Uh, the, uh, okay. So
I have a, I'm going to,
I'm going to ask about an edge case
because I love asking these absurd or
extreme questions,
but if someone has an unlimited,
a nearly unlimited or unlimited budget,
let's just say it's a hedge fund
manager who's worth $1 billion plus,
and you are their personal sort of a
security consultant and you can interpret
that any way you'd like, uh, uh,
security slash sort of a Armageddon
proofing consultant. What are,
what are some of the things
that you would have them do?
I would have them hire a guy who didn't
discuss their security plan on a podcast
with Tim Ferriss. I first piece
of advice. Right. Good advice.
Don't do that. Um, but generally
speaking, uh, you know,
every person you work with
is a unique and different,
so I work with a lot of folks have
high net worth and a lot of the general
public corporations and the advice is
very specific on what people's threats
are. So for some people the
biggest threat, you know,
to a hedge fund manager may be that
their son or daughter is addicted to meth
and that's bringing all types of other,
you know,
people into their home that
causes them a difficulty. I,
in others it may be some of their
personal proclivities things that they're
looking for online that could
be personally embarrassing,
you know, mistress,
his extramarital affairs,
all of that type of stuff.
So those are the general things that
you look at and then you work up a pret,
a threat profile. That's something that
I find that most individuals don't do.
And certainly most corporations don't do.
And the fact of the matter is in the
same way that hackers are using the
internet to gather lots of
information about their targets,
you yourself can go out there and use
tools and you talked about reputation.com
and others,
but there are lots tools out there that
will allow people to get really good
open source information on themselves
and the threats against them.
And that's one of the key steps that I
always mentioned to my corporate clients
is that they need to go
ahead and implement an open
source intelligence program.
Because if you are working
on a secret project,
let's say you know it's the latest
iPhone or you're working on the latest
version of Android, something that
you don't want people to know about.
If you're got your search engines up
and running and you start seeing people
talking about it or sales lists
are leaking out there or employees,
resumes are out there showing that
they're about to jump to the competition.
You know, there's just a lot
of stuff that you can detect.
And the other point that I tell them
is in most people don't realize this is
make sure that you're looking in the
digital underground. So most people think,
you know,
when they search Google,
they're searching the internet and
when you're searching Google in reality
you're only searching about
0.03% of all the available uh,
electronic information
stored on the planet.
So how do you go about searching
the digital underground? Ah,
you have to go onto ground.
The quickest way to do that,
I mean one of the ways that people do
it is by using tor, the onion router.
So that's a specialized piece of software
actually produced by the U s navy.
And it was meant originally to help a
democracy and human rights activists
overseas bypass their national firewalls,
whether in China or Iran so that they
can get around to communicate and it was
very useful for their personal safety.
And there's a million great reasons
why you would use tour. Again,
if you want in the wake of Snowden,
if you wanted to go ahead and have good
encryption of the information you're
looking for it,
then a tour is a great,
a useful tool for that with
some noted limitations.
But the other side of that is that there's
something called Tor hidden services.
And if you're running this
particular piece of software,
you can now get access to a whole
world that you don't know exist.
So this is where hackers and terrorists
and activists and spy agencies and law
enforcement hang out. So I'm sure you
will be familiar with the Silk Road,
uh,
and what went on in that case.
It broke very close to you
in San Francisco and the
fact of the matter is dread
pirate Roberts,
the alleged person who was running
that had the largest drug website,
uh,
in the world.
And whether or not you like drugs or
not and whatever your position may be,
a National Institute of Health, uh, uh,
drug abuse agency study said at some point
20% of all narcotics purchased in the
United States transmitted the Silk Road.
Wow.
I had no idea the number was so big.
And the money that dread pirate Roberts
brought in in those 30 months was one
point $2 billion.
So one point $2 billion and
30 months of methamphetamine,
AK 47 uzis child pornography,
fake passports,
whenever you're looking for,
you could buy it there.
And because a silk road operated kind of
like Ebay where the house took a cut of
everything,
they sold a dread pirate
Roberts is alleged to have
a master personal fortune of
$110 million. So, you know,
let's say you're a 28 year
old entrepreneur and kids
don't do this out there,
but if you're a 28 year old
entrepreneur, you know, getting, uh,
going from zero to one point
$2 billion in 30 months,
he had a relatively successful exit except
for the life imprisonment he's facing.
But other than that, you
know, pretty good Gig,
right? The, uh, the rather
punishing a asterisk. Yes,
exactly. Oh, no. Income
statement notes. Yeah. Comes,
comes with free imprisonment for life
and free prison companions. Oh God.
Uh, the, the, um, see, see,
you mentioned drugs. Uh,
I want to chat about that for a second
because I, I've heard you mention,
and maybe you can elaborate
on, um, drug production.
So this is something that I'm
very fascinated by. I mean, uh,
I think drugs is a bit of a,
so the in the Nancy Reagan say no to
drugs since it's a bit broad, I think, uh,
it's a lot gets mixed into this so called
war on drugs that that shouldn't be
part of it at all. And a lot
of good therapeutic agents
get disregarded and blah,
blah blah. But the point being when you
look at just some of the real cash cows,
if you look at the, the opiates, right?
If you look at the look at heroin,
you look at cocaine, um, you know,
marijuana is very interesting case.
We won't get too far into
that. But just the, uh,
the sort of decriminalization of marijuana
is really fascinating, but isn't it,
it's used mandatory in San Francisco.
It's brilliantly, it's pretty.
If you're going to Dolores Park,
you by law required to it. Yes,
we are using marijuana. Yeah. If you skip,
if you stub your toe and therefore
have chronic pain, then you,
you're permanently disabled. Yes. And
now you need mouth. But I've heard,
and I can't, I haven't verified
this, but there are a poppy fields,
uh,
even within some national parks in
the US that are policed by Mexican,
uh,
narcos.
And you have to be careful even as a
hiker in some cases if you go too far off
the beaten path,
uh,
is that going to change in
so much as we'll drugs? Uh,
the example that you used was a involving
yeast to synthetically produce cocaine
are not synthetically perhaps,
but in a,
I guess it would be synthetically
produced cocaine or other drugs like that.
Are these, are these fields,
is that entire production
chain and all the shipment?
Is that just going to go away?
Yeah, so you've hit on a really, really
interesting point, which is, uh, you know,
in the same way that apple can go ahead
and disrupt Microsoft and Google can
disrupt, you know, uh, somebody
else. The fact of the matter is,
is that the old school,
original gangsters and narco dealers are
going to be faced with some challenges
to their business model from and
new generation of joke dealers.
Uh, and it's going to be really
fascinating. So to your point,
when you think about what is required for
the production of cocaine today or her
wind,
right?
You need these massive fields of cocoa
leaves a marijuana plants or poppy
plants, et cetera. And that is a
really tough for the dope dealers,
either expensive to Maine,
they have a very huge footprint in terms
of hectors and hectors of fields that
need to be maintained. And they're easy
for law enforcement to detect. So now,
thanks to synthetic biology,
one of the amazing things that you can
do is because all of those marijuana
poppy,
uh,
or coca plants are all naturally
occurring substances that contain DNA.
You can actually go in and
sequence cocaine plant or
poppy seed or any of those
things. And from that, deduce
the genetic code for Coco.
And you can go further in and say,
well, what's the active ingredient here?
And you can isolate that and you can
snip that part of the plant or the active
ingredient and you could insert it into
yeast and then you could grow those e's
and you could bake bread with it
and you could make a beer with it.
So we're not quite there yet,
but all of these things are on very close
off on the horizon and it completely
breaks our current global security
model around narcotics. Because again,
we have these,
you know,
big fields and we look for the big fields
and we have a dope sniffing dogs when
you arrive at the airport or going
through customs and immigration,
but they're not going to smell,
you know,
a loaf of bread that is
just as powerful as cocaine.
So there's some really interesting
opportunities there moving forward.
It's going to make for some really
interesting beer and bread in the future.
Is it conceivable?
This is just now I'm going to really
go off the deep end into my, uh,
sort of detective novel mode,
but is it,
is it conceivable that the u s
government could decide that it would be
pragmatic to in some way seed people
domestically with technology too,
in a very, uh, decentralized
way, produce meaning,
synthesize cocaine, heroin, et Cetera, uh,
to disrupt the,
uh,
the incentives and finances of say,
cartels who are shuttling drugs,
uh, from, and I know the, the,
the Mexican cartels are
now is as far south as, uh,
as Columbia where I've spent
some time very, very prevalent,
but basically in a way to reduce
violence and disrupt that chain.
Do you think there's any conceivable
scenario in which the government or some
facet of, um, law enforcement
would decide that that type of, uh,
even the introduction of that type
of production would either be done
deliberately or a,
uh,
or have a blind eye has to it to,
um,
for the tradeoff,
which is disrupting the immensely
violence and problematic influence of the
cartels in Mexico?
Yeah,
I mean,
you're asking for a particularly
interesting public and political question.
There are plenty of folks
who are advocating for this.
There's a great talk by a gentleman called
Ethan Nadelmann who I just saw speak
down at Ted Global,
uh,
who really gives a very powerful and
compelling talk for why drugs should be
legalized. And you know, you can Google
that and find his talk. Um, there are,
you know,
we're kind of seeing the beginnings of
that now with marijuana and there are
other countries like the
Netherlands than have, you know,
allowed people to be on heroin for
years and put them on Methadone.
So there've been lots of different
experiments around this. I would say.
I don't know that the public policy and
more importantly the politics around
this is there yet. But, uh,
you can certainly look at the cost of
what it is doing to our society. Uh,
particularly here in the United States.
We have the largest incarcerated
population in the world.
I think there are something
like 3 million people, uh,
that are somehow in the criminal justice
system at state pen or at the local
level, uh, in federal penitentiary.
So the cost of maintaining that,
and most of those folks are there
for drugs one way or the other.
So there's certainly an economic
cause to be put forth. And again,
I'd refer you to Ethan Nadelmann,
who makes that way better than I can.
I don't know that the government,
uh,
anytime soon is going to see this more
as a public health issue and focus on
demand reduction right now,
public policy,
the United States has been almost a
heavily geared towards a supply reduction.
So, you know, let's go
ahead and, you know,
drop napalm on cocaine fields and Columbia
and that'll solve it. And of course,
the, as the, the people in Latin America,
the Mexican president and others have
mentioned, uh, well, don't blame us.
You guys are the ones that want to buy
it. So it's really complex, right? Um,
how this works. I will mention that the
narcos are all over the drug trade, uh,
from all over the technology, uh,
space, uh, in really amazing ways.
So Narchos are using robots, they are
flying drones, they've got drug subs.
Um,
there are now a quad copter drones in
octocopter drones that can carry like
thousand kilo,
uh,
loads of cocaine and marijuana
across the Mexican American border.
We're starting to see that there are
2000 tons carried by remote controlled a
narco subs.
The,
some of the Colombian cartels
literally have a r and d budget.
So the cocaine cartels in Colombia had
like $5 million allocated to r and D for
robotics because the day that they can
launch autonomous subs up against North
America,
they've hit pay dirt.
So we're seeing that and the
money and the sums are involved.
We were talking earlier about how
clever a terrorist may or may not be.
You should look at the sophistication
among the narcos and the money that they
have allows them to bring in
tremendous talent. Uh, El Chapo,
Joaquin Guzman who ran the scene on Lola
cartel was recently arrested in Mexico.
And at the time of his arrest,
he had a room in his mansion,
a cash room with $200 million
in cash just sitting his house.
We call that the Tim Ferriss Room,
obviously for obvious reasons,
but he was actually listed at number one
on the Forbes wealthiest list ahead of
Oprah and French President Sarcozi.
Right. So the amount of money, by the way,
to put $200 million in perspective,
Interpol's annual budget is $90 million.
Wow.
So you were a sports team that you
would bet on that sports team against
Interpol in a heartbeat.
And it would seem to be the wiser bit.
Yes. In terms of talent
recruitment, he should have,
he should have a number
of incentives to use.
I will kill you or you work for me or
exactly how we'll give you twice as much
as anyone else, any other law enforcement
agency or at least Interpol can pay it.
And by the way, that's exactly
happening right now. There's, you know,
we were kind of joking about what's
going on with the narco wars in Mexico,
but there have been 50,000
innocent medic Mexican citizens,
nationals that have been
slayed in the past six years.
So just south of our border,
50,000 people, right? You know,
more than live in Palo Alto
or the suburb of New York, uh,
had been murdered.
And so there's a massive war going on
between the people we talked about crowd
sourcing before.
There's a ton of incredibly brave.
I'm Mexican citizens who actually crowd
sourcing the location and activities of
the narcos and, uh, they're,
they're using open source tools like
Google maps to report dope dealers and
bring that information forward.
The dope dealers have gotten hip to
that and if now actually gone ahead and
killed off a bunch of these
citizen reporters and so, uh,
to protect themselves.
Now those guys are using encryption
and then narcos have gone out there and
actually kidnapped hackers.
They've kidnapped,
like top hackers off the
street and brought them back
to their headquarters and
say, hey, you decrypt this
or I'm gonna kill you. Uh,
and the payback once somebody
is identified as being
a potential snitch, uh,
for the narcos have been
draconian. I, you know,
it's kind of gross and you can
edit this out if you need be,
but to make their points,
some of the Narchos have gone ahead and
kidnap some of these folks were using
tools like Google maps too,
to crowdsource what was going on with
the drug dealers in their activities,
kidnap them,
uh,
and killed them and decapitating
them and taking their heads, uh,
and brought them to the central square
of the town like right in front of the
church when everybody shows up on
Sunday morning and they took two, uh,
computer keyboards,
put them in the town square in front of
the church that everybody shows up at
with the head.
The human head of this niche right there
and with a note in big letters is that
this is what happens to rats.
I horrifying of course.
And the,
the number that I have so much
trouble grasping is 50,000.
It's so many people, uh, are, what,
how does that break down?
If you're looking at the pie chart
of reasons for these deaths, um,
how many of them are snitches or what
percentage versus a stray bullets and just
collateral damage,
shotgun,
all campaigns to instill fear and terror
into entire cities and to compliance.
Because I, I've, I've read these stories
of say 20 or 50 students being killed,
right? We had that right now in the past
couple of weeks we've had all these,
you know,
innocent high school students who were
just murdered allegedly by the mayor and
the police in the town. So, you
know, I could make up a story,
but I don't know the exact
breakdown of what it is.
My Gut tells me based upon what I've read
in research that brought in, you know,
there's some percentage of this that
his drug dealer on drug dealer violence.
So one cartel fighting with another,
the others are people that won't go along
with the narcos and what they are up
against and what they want to do.
So they get taken out,
law enforcement officers get taken out.
And then there's just a tremendous
number of casualties when you know,
the trucks come through the little town
and everybody's shooting eight ks and
[inaudible] and then you know,
five year olds get gunned down, uh,
is kind of collateral damage,
man.
Good to count,
count our blessings when you don't
have to contend with that on a,
on a regular basis or an anytime
basis. It's really horrifying, uh,
to,
to just maybe project forward a bit and
I'm not sure if it's projecting forward
that far in fact, but
artificial intelligence, uh,
there are a lot of different
differing opinions on this,
but what are the threats,
if any,
of artificial intelligence and where are
things now versus where you think they
might be?
That is a great question. You know, it's
actually very much in the news today.
Elon Musk and I quote him in my book
talks about the threat from AI being
greater than nukes.
And uh,
Stephen Hawking actually put an op Ed in
the independent in London about a month
or two ago where he was very cautious
about a widespread adoption of Ai.
Just for folks who aren't particularly
familiar with Ai. Um, you know,
there are generally two types.
There's the narrow AI that's
the artificial intelligence
that goes ahead and
puts a recommendation for you out there
on Netflix or Amazon about what book you
might like. If you enjoyed this
movie, you might like this movie.
So that kind of narrow AI is widespread
and ubiquitous. It's, you know,
AI that allows you to talk to American
Airlines while you're on hold.
And we're seeing that every place.
And then there's the broader
and more widespread AI,
which is kind of a artificial general
intelligence that's kind of the skynet AI
that people fear. We'll run the planet.
And there were some concerns about both,
broadly speaking, you know, we all saw,
or most of us may have seen the television
episode for a jeopardy when Ibm's
Watson was playing. Did you happen to
catch that? I didn't personally see it.
So it's,
you know,
IBM built this computer called Watson
and it's doing a narrow AI in a plate
against the top, top jeopardy champs
and just kick their butts. Right?
So this big computer with a funny voice
called Watson was able to be the best
champions in the world. Uh,
jeopardy. And before that, you know,
we had our greatest chess
champions being beaten by computer.
But the question that people don't realize
or don't often ask themselves is what
would happen if Watson turned
to a life of crime, right?
How much health care
fraud could Watson commit,
how much identity theft
could wants and commit?
The fact of the matter is
is that day in and day out,
we're turning over more and
more of our lives to algorithms.
People worry about individual
bits of data being stolen,
but that's like kind of a low level
threat. Of course that's happening.
The bigger threat is having our algorithm
hacks algorithms are very complex
mathematical formula that go out there
and carry out everything from the anti
brake system in your car to the GPS and
navigation used by aircraft around the
world to a all the trading on the stock
floors. And those are all algorithms.
And we've seen a couple of really crazy
wacky things going on in the world of
algorithms to such, you know, which
look like market manipulation.
The challenges is that Moore's
law applies to criminals as well.
And the big paradigm shift in crime
has been as a result of algorithmic
programming.
So in the book I talk about the fact that
the old paradigm of crime is you get a
bad guy,
he goes out and buys a knife or gun hides
in a dark alley and says stick 'em up.
Right? That was a good, that was a good
business. You could be your own boss,
set your own hours. Startup
costs were low, but Tim,
you know this better than anybody else.
What was his problem? It didn't scale.
How do you scale your business? Right?
That was tough for a criminal. Exactly.
And, and everybody, you rob might shoot
back and kill you. Right? Um, so, uh,
technology came along that actually
improved upon that business model and the
technology was the locomotive. Now,
rather than robbing one person at a time,
we could rob 200 people at a time.
Now when they created trains,
nobody thought about that.
But of course that was a consequence.
Fast forward today to the days of the
Internet and we've had hacks like at
target and the Sony playstation hack
before that were 100 million people were
simultaneously, uh, victims
of a crime in the target hack.
One third of all Americans
were effected by that.
So if you talk about exponentials,
we've gone from criminals robbing one
person to one single lone individual being
able to rob 100 million people.
That is a complete paradigm shift in
crime. And because it's exponential,
it's only going to grow.
And so my big fear and concern that
I write about in future crimes,
the book is the fact that our systems
of justice and law and order and public
safety are all deeply,
deeply linear.
And yet the threat is
entirely exponential.
And we're seeing criminals use algorithms,
right?
You know why you can rob 100 million
people because computer crime has been
reduced to an algorithm. The old days, I
talked about the movie war games earlier.
The old day was you'd have the,
you know,
high school kid with the
bag of Doritos and you know,
monster or red bull sitting is
computer hacking away at all hours.
You don't need to do that any more. You
can write scripts that carry out crime.
You've heard of software as a service.
Guess what? There's crime as a service.
You can actually go out there and buy
programs like black shades and others that
will go out there and
commit crime for you.
And so when a computer program
can do the identity theft,
can do the denial of service
attacks can do that for you.
It can run in the background
24, seven, you know, uh,
365 days a year to carry out that crime.
That's why it's skills and that's why
the profits are so high. And you know,
a lot of the principles in the four
hour workweek have been implemented by
organized crime.
I'm not saying they read your book,
but I'm saying that the logic that
you developed in a lot of this, uh,
you know,
people are seeing that.
And so now we have fully automated crime
and its algorithms that are carrying it
out.
And Ai.
Yeah, it's a, I mean, these,
these principles and whenever you look
at principles for effectiveness and
efficiency or scaling or building
an organization, they can,
they can of course cut both ways.
I mean, they can be used as a,
as a surgical tool to do good things they
can use. B is to decapitate people, the,
you know, metaphorically or
physically, uh, even. But, um,
and that's an important point I'd love
to make is, I'm not saying by the way,
technology is bad. You know, I
like you live in Silicon Valley,
I'm a huge proponent of technology.
It has the opportunity to bring tremendous
abundance and positive good to the
world.
But as you mentioned,
whether it be a knife can be used by a
surgeon to heal or by a criminal to kill.
And it's just about how we use it.
No, absolutely. And I'd
love to, to chat. Uh,
I know we're probably going
to be wrapping up pretty soon,
but I wanted to ask you
just about what can be done.
So let's assume that the people
listening are, are for the most part,
not going to,
uh,
they're not going to feel compelled to
dig a spider hole and their backyard
because they're afraid the black
helicopters are going to come for them.
And you know,
they're going to fight off the u s
government with their stash of canyons.
Let's just assume that that's not
who we're talking to primarily.
But for people who were
like, all right, I'm busy,
I've got a little bit of
money and well educated.
I'm very worried about doing stupid
things that compromise me. Uh, you know,
what are,
what are a handful of simple steps that
they should take a or might consider
taking to decrease the odds
of bad things happening?
Uh, well I can throw out some tips for
individuals and then some for startups and
companies. So, uh, on the
individual front, you know,
common sense actually is not so common.
And the number of people that will click
on links and open attachments is really
high as a really strong piece of advice.
Just don't do that.
It's really bad cyber hygiene.
And I talk about the concept of cyber
hygiene and the idea of keeping yourself
clean. And if you think about, you know,
sexually transmitted diseases, right?
If you're not cleaning your
transmitted to other people,
the same is true with our
computers. So don't do the hat. Uh,
another thing that you can do is make
sure that your computer or your mobile
phone is constantly up to date.
Have you ever been sitting in front
of your computer when you get a little
notification like,
hey,
there's a new update to windows or there's
a new update to Ios or something like
that. Have you come across those? Sure.
Yeah, I get notifications all the time,
right? So what people don't,
what that isn't saying,
it sounds really nice when they
say, oh, there's an update.
What it really means is our secure,
our software has been riddled with
security holes for the past six months,
you know, since the previous update.
And we're now finally fixing them.
So you know,
there's the flip side of that.
I would say always make sure that your
software is up to date across all of your
devices and UNC keep that updated.
Another thing you can do, a,
I am not a fan of single sign on and
using the same password to log on to,
you know,
all your services.
The challenge with that is if your
account at target gets hacked and you use
your same target email and
login a across multiple sites.
Now the bad guys,
and they do routinely do this once,
they get 100 million accounts from target,
they're taking your target, you know,
name and password and they're trying
it at Bank of America and Citi Bank and
they're trying to get
a Facebook and Google.
So if you ha you should definitely have
a different name and password for all of
your sites. And I know people say to me
a great mark, how am I going to remember,
you know,
300 passwords and this one wants a
capital letter and the other one wants the
name of my favorite a child actress.
And it's all too complex.
There are a number of pieces of
software out there called a password.
Managers are password wallets that I
recommend you have to use some caution
because guess what? Organized crime have
created their own versions of those.
So they call,
they'll upload something.
It's like super number one best password
program and get it into the android
play star and tens of thousands
of people download it.
And of course your passwords are just
being fed to organized crime in the
background. So I recommend
a one password. Uh,
there's another one called last pass,
which is quite good.
And then there's key pass, k, e p a,
s, s which is an open source version.
So definitely do not use the same
password if you're in a public space.
Always make sure that you use a Vpn,
a virtual private network.
This way any of the information that
is transiting from your computer to the
Internet is encrypted from
that point to point a.
If you're not and you're
sitting at a local Starbucks,
I can go ahead and just because
we're on the same network,
see everything you're
doing on your computer.
There was a hack of years ago called
fire sheep where I could steal your
Facebook session cookie and log in is
you and post things to your Facebook
account. Just because we were on the
same network and you didn't need to be
sophisticated.
Actually it was just a browsing for a
Firefox browser that allowed me to hack.
So the tools of hacking are
becoming particularly, um, you know,
easy to use. Um, so if you do those
things, if you maintain your site,
if you go ahead and constantly updating
them and use password managers,
you can actually avoid 85% of the threats
out there. So you can make a massive,
massive difference.
The last one that I tell people that most
folks don't consider is do not use the
admin account from your own
computer as your primary account.
So if you have, you
know, on your computer,
a Tim Ferriss account, that account
should not have administrative privileges.
You should have a primary account,
which is administrative privileges and
the one that you use day in and day out
should be a user account with degraded
non administrative privileges.
Why would you do that?
Because if you click on the email from
the Nigerian prince by accident and get
your computer infected, if you're
already logged in under admin account,
then that code needs no
further permissions to go
ahead and infect you and to
get onto your machine.
But if you're on a user account and you
get that infection in order to change
the system files,
it will ask you to enter in your password,
which should be a good clue
that you've been hacked.
Got It. Okay, so you're talking
about for the the computer access,
the local computer access,
correct. Yeah. If you're logged
onto your personal, you know,
your Mac book air or a windows machine
or a Samsung machine, whatever it is,
your laptop,
your home computer,
it's really wise to never
run it as an administrator.
God, it's okay. No, that makes
sense. And just to add to your,
your password recommendation, which
I think is a smart one, you know,
whether it's one password,
lastpass or otherwise, is uh,
enabling two step authentication.
Uh,
excellent is really a good
idea for, you know, for Gmail,
for Facebook, for any
account that you can to, uh,
enable two step authentication for those
people listening who don't know what
that is, it's usually within
setting somewhere. And all
that means is if you try,
if you or someone else tries to log
in to say your Gmail account from an
unrecognized computer,
it's going to shoot you a typically a
very often a text to your cell phone with
a pass key that you need to enter in
order to then enter your password.
So it's just another barrier, so to
speak. It's a great piece of advice. Uh,
what about,
so with the startups,
are there any other pieces of advice that
you would have a low hanging fruit for
those folks?
Well. So for the folks that are
working in the startup, we're holding,
I advise a lot of different startups
as I know that you do. You know,
they're running around crazy
trying to get their beta out there.
They want to get this ship, their
code, whatever their product is.
And so probably the very last
thing on their list is security.
They don't think about it and so forth.
A company you need to think
about these issues, right?
Because all you have is
your intellectual property.
And there are actually companies
out there that specialize, you know,
the minute Facebook has launched,
they create the German version of Facebook
and they create the Chinese version
of Ebay. And so ripping off your
IP very much what they do. So, uh,
both for startups and particularly
for larger corporations,
one thing I often suggest is that you
need to be keenly aware of what's going on
with your competition and
with your own company.
So that goes back to implementing an
open source intelligence program. Uh,
you also need to have somebody who is
in charge of your security and kind of
thinks, you know, you know,
with the more of a conspiratorial
mindset that you and I seem to have a in
talking about this stuff and
figuring out what can go wrong.
Because most people are good people.
They don't think like bad guys. Right?
And I put handcuffs on bad guys
for 20 years all over the world.
I know how they think. So if you're not
trained in that, it's not at all obvious.
Um,
it's also important to realize that not
everything needs to go into a computer.
Both Coca Cola and Kentucky Fried Chicken,
KFC,
the secret recipes for their food is
not in any electronic system and be
retrieved. It's air gapped,
written down on a piece of paper.
So if it's really important,
uh, think about that.
We talked about some of
the travel tips earlier.
The last thing that I would mention is
to red team and test your assumptions.
Red Team is a term from the military.
You kind of have the blue
team and the right team.
The blue team is United States.
The red team is always the bad guys in
the military trains this way where they
use, you know, sets of bad guys
to try to break their stuff.
I can guarantee you that if you're doing
anything interesting on the internet or
in your personal life, there's somebody
who's trying to get access to it.
It may not be an individual hacker sitting
at a keyboard targeting you because
as I mentioned earlier, a lot of
these attacks can be scripted. I,
the thing I hear all the time
is, oh, I've got nothing to hide.
I've got nothing to lose. Then you
don't lead a very interesting life.
If that's the case, um, I would think
we all have something at risk here.
And so you should be
testing those assumptions.
And because if you're not
trying to hack yourself,
the bad guys are so better that
you uncover those threats first.
No, definitely. And just to your point, I
mean there's some real hot beds, I think,
I want to say Estonia for some reason,
but it might be brought a Slava
somewhere out in that neck of the woods.
I mean their, their entire cottage
industries that have popped up in Romania,
Romania,
it's actually called like,
you know,
the cybercrime headquarters of
the world where it's very funny,
they have something like
500 people in this village,
but that one western union office in
Romania does more than most of western
Europe because of all the
illegal cybercrime payments
coming in there. So, uh,
and in Nigeria they have what
are called the Yahoo Boys.
These are the ones that send out
all of those emails, you know,
trying to trick you.
So yeah,
there's definitely a very vibrant
cybercrime economy out there.
A study by McAfee and CSI has,
I think tank in DC estimated the global
cyber economy at $400 billion a year.
It's tremendous.
That is so wild. Yeah. And growing,
uh, no, uh, no doubt about it.
Uh, well I would, uh,
I think this is a good round
two round one rather for us.
I'm already looking for around two.
So I think,
I think this is a good
introduction for folks,
gives them plenty to think
about. Uh, any, uh, okay,
here's one for you.
Do you have any habits
that a peep that may,
might be nonobvious to
people or our habits that you
think improve your security
or give you peace of mind that,
uh, other people find odd?
Well,
one that I get commented on all the time
is if you look at any of my devices,
whether it be my cell phone and
my laptop or my computers at home,
they all have yellow stickies over
the camera. The fact of the matter is,
is that not only can
people hack your camera,
but they can hack it in a way such that
the little green or red light isn't on.
And we had, there's malware out there,
so that does this really easily.
I mentioned black shades
earlier that we'll do that. Uh,
there was a girl called Cassidy wolf
who was miss teen America and she went
ahead and had her camera taken over.
Ultimately we found out
by one of her classmates,
she clicked on infected email
and as miss teen America,
17 year old girl was coming out
of her own bathroom. You know,
after taking a shower,
her laptop was open.
This creep was going ahead
and surreptitiously filming
her and taking the video
and then blackmailed her
and said, hey, you know,
if you don't do specific sex acts
for me in front of the video,
I'm going to release all this stuff
live. Uh, so I, uh, unlike teen America,
people are not lying naked,
but I still go ahead and cover up the
video camera and it's super cheap to do
and it's, you know, it's, it's
just something to keep in mind.
So funny you mentioned that
I have masking tape over my,
over my camera on my laptop right now
because I was hanging out with a buddy of
mine who in a previous life got in a
lot of trouble with the FBI for hacking.
He is a, he is a world
class hacker. He, I mean,
if you want to talk about a very
competent red team, he now gets it.
He now gets paid by companies to do that,
to try to beat their systems,
which he usually does successfully.
Uh, and he said, you know,
you might wanna put some tape on that. And
I was like, what are you talking about?
And he's like, well, like if I wanted to
hijack your computer and videotape you,
I could do it pretty easily. And I
was like, okay, say no more. Right.
Uh, and I've actually heard of business
travelers who have been blackmailed very
similarly.
Uh,
usually female travelers who have
had people attach cameras to their,
their hotel up peoples
from the opposite side.
And so business travelers,
there's some different business travelers
I know who will similarly cover up
that, um, cover up that
keyhole so that, uh,
people cannot surveil them.
Absolutely. Talking
about cameras, you know,
I mentioned earlier that everything is
becoming software or hardware and the
cameras are perfect example of that.
You know,
we all go ahead and
have cameras around us,
not just on our cell phones are on our
laptops, but everywhere we go, right,
there are now cameras at the dry cleaners,
cameras at the bakery, cameras at the,
and all of those cameras are connected
to the Internet and they're all hackable.
And some crazy number,
like 30 to 40% of all camera
systems have absolutely no password.
And another 30 or 40% have the admin
password that's written in the manual
that's available on pdf on the internet.
If you Google the name
of the camera system.
So that means they're widely
available to be hacked.
And yet people use things like
baby monitors, nanny cams,
things like that to protect themselves.
And we're finding that a,
they're just easy marks. Within
the past week actually, uh,
here in late October,
we had an incident where it was reported
that 76,000 camera systems had been
compromised and we're being
live streamed to the web.
So you could log in because all of these
cameras that had been hacked and easily
taken over and you could see
women sitting on the couch,
you could see people in
their bedroom having sex.
You could see mothers breastfeeding their
kids, people sitting in dry cleaners,
you know,
cooking stuff at bakeries.
So we think these systems
are there to protect us,
but in fact they can be compromised and
used in really interesting ways if you
have time. I'll tell you
another funny story about that.
I have time.
Awesome. There was a case called the
crown casino in Melbourne, Australia.
This happened about a year ago and a man
comes in and starts playing poker and
he's doing really, really well.
He ends up playing for two days,
almost straight and he walks away
from the crown casino in Melbourne,
Australia with $33 million playing poker,
gets back on a plane and flies
back to his home country in Asia.
What the hell happened? Because the
casino got cleaned out. They had no idea.
They ended up looking at it and it turns
out that he was part of a hacker team
that went ahead and hacked the
security cameras in casinos. You know,
all casinos have a ton of cameras and
the hackers that were working with this
guy had given him an earpiece. And
so with the, by having common deer,
the casinos own security system that
could see perfectly clearly what the
dealer's cards are and the players of
all the different players at the table.
And they were basically via electronic
message into his ear, telling him,
you know, stay pat whole DoubleDown all of
that stuff. And just 48 hours, you know,
33 million bucks.
So the cameras that are meant to protect
us if they're not locked down and
encrypted can definitely
be used against us.
Wow. Yeah. Good. Good luck.
Extraditing that guy. Yeah, exactly.
Aww Man, he can now afford
a good defense. I bet.
Wow. Well, there's so much more
to talk about, but uh, I will, uh,
I will certainly look forward
to some follow on conversations.
Maybe we'll inject some wine into the,
into the mix to make things a more
rambunctious. But, uh, but, uh,
since I know we're,
we're practically neighbors,
I even know we're doing
this virtually, uh, the,
I would love to meet you in person someday
and hang out again. Likewise. And, uh,
the,
the recommendation I'd make to folks
is a good a future crimes.com check.
Check this out.
And Mark did me a very big favor by
coming on the show early for you guys.
And, uh, do me the favor.
The book is very inexpensive,
it's going to be spectacular
preorder the book. So just it's,
it'll take two seconds, grab it on Amazon
or wherever, uh, future crimes.com.
Check it out, definitely take
a look at his tedtalk. Uh,
where else should they should
or can they find you where,
uh, I'm at singularity
university, so I teach there,
we have a bunch of great
executive programs and uh,
other than that on a plane
somewhere to travel in the world.
So singularity university
is fascinating guys.
If you really want to train yourself to
think about exponential or exponentially
growing technologies in a
new way to expand your mind,
I can guarantee that singularity you
will help and that's what it is on,
on the web. Singularity U. Dot Org
can take a look at everything there.
And uh,
I will also include links to various
resources and books and whatnot that we
mentioned in this episode as well as
a future crimes in the show notes.
For those of you listening who do,
who want to simply find the one stop
shopping for everything we talked about.
Go to four hour work week.com forward
slash podcast all spelled out and mark
until next time. Thanks so much for
taking the time. This was a blast.
This was awesome, Tim. Thank you. Thank
you so much.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show
is brought to you by 99 designs and
ex-officio 99 designs is the world's
largest online marketplace of graphic
designers and I have used 99 designs for
years including to get cover concepts
for the four hour body which went on to
become number one New York Times Number
One Wall Street Journal.
It was a huge hit and here's how it
works and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions.
You can see these book covers and so
on@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim
with you need a logo, car
wrap, a web design and APP,
a thumbnail t-shirt,
whatever.
You go to 99 designs.com you describe
your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around
the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas
and designs and drafts.
You have an original design that you
love or you pay nothing. It is fantastic.
I have used it.
I have mentioned it before,
including in the four hour work
week as a resource. Check it out,
99 designs.com forward slash Tim and if
you use that link you'll be able to see
what I've done on the platform.
You will also get $99
as an upgrade for free,
which will get you more designs,
more submissions. So check it out.
Ex-Officio boy, where do I begin? I
have a long history with ex-officio.
Ex-Officio makes clothing and as far
back as 2007 2008 I had a hit video that
went viral called how to travel
the world with 10 pounds or less.
And I talked about ex-officio underwear.
Ex-Officio underwear is lightweight,
ultra lightweight, quick
drying and antimicrobial.
Why is this important? Well,
I've gone through 20 plus countries
with two pairs of underwear before,
both from ex-officio, and I'm not
alone in this. This might sound crazy,
but a lot of executives, for
instance, we'll take this underwear,
they'll wash it in the sink or
somewhere else, roll it up into towel,
like a Burrito step on it, and a few
hours later they are completely dry,
completely clean. You don't
have to just have to, and yes,
they have to be comfortable
for all day wear,
but check out their clothing
as well as their underwear.
You can go to ex-officio dot com
forward slash Tim, that's x, e, x, O,
f, F, I, C, I, o.com forward slash
Tim and you can see this video,
which has a bunch of other packing tips,
but this underwear,
this clothing is not just for the
gents ladies. You have choices too.
And they really have an
incredible collection of high
quality products that I've
used for almost 10 years now.
So check them out.
EX-OFFICIO DOT com forward
slash Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.